Katrina: 音不准吗
Katrina: Is the sound off?
Shure: 不是这个夹子有点夹不紧有点松
Shure: No, this clip is a bit loose.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 录一下
Katrina: Record this.
Katrina: 录到你的洞洞鞋
Katrina: Record your Crocs.
Shure: 哈哈你搞搞事情了是吗
Shure: Haha, are you trying to make trouble?
Katrina: 哈哈有点赖吧
Katrina: Haha, a bit cheeky, huh?
Jake:常务记一下这个
Jake: Note this down.
Jake:5:1017:11
Jake: 5:10, 17:11
Katrina: 直接给你这样吧
Katrina: I'll just give it to you like this.
Jake:对对叫什么呀
Jake: Yeah, yeah, what is it?
Shure: 对齐
Shure: Align it.
Katrina: 但我穿睡
Katrina: But I'm in my pajamas.
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Shure: 停停停卡卡卡卡
Shure: Stop, stop, stop, cut, cut, cut.
Jake:我的虫虫
Jake: My bug.
Jake:对了鬼关了好好
Jake: Alright, turn it off, good.
Katrina: 重来
Katrina: Do it again.
Katrina: 卡了最后一句
Katrina: The last sentence got stuck.
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: It's done.
Shure: 非常好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 雨轩老师唱功了得
Shure: Teacher Yuxuan's singing is impressive.
Shure: 雨轩老师还有什么想唱的歌
Shure: Teacher Yuxuan, is there any other song you want to sing?
Shure: 我尽量的都帮你弹一弹
Shure: I'll try to play it for you.
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh...
Katrina: 我看看
Katrina: Let me see.
Katrina: 我还有什么想唱的
Katrina: What else do I want to sing...
Katrina: 你都能弹
Katrina: You can play anything?
Katrina: 噢 泪桥你听过没有
Katrina: Oh, have you heard of "Bridge of Tears"?
Katrina: 伍佰的那个
Katrina: The one by Wu Bai.
Shure: 那我应该知道
Shure: I think I know that one.
Katrina: 唉这也一了半天
Katrina: Ah, this one took a while.
Shure: 是这个调调吧
Shure: Is it this tune?
Katrina: 好像有点高
Katrina: Seems a bit high.
Shure: 不不不会唱这个是
Shure: No, no, I can't sing this one.
Katrina: 这好像是伍佰原版就是偏摇滚的那种
Katrina: This seems like the original version by Wu Bai, it's more rock.
Katrina: 就被人改编偏民谣的那种感觉
Katrina: Someone adapted it to have a more folk vibe.
Katrina: 我看看啊还有什么比较熟悉的
Katrina: Let me see, what else am I more familiar with...
Katrina: 小雨你听过吗甘小雨
Katrina: Xiaoyu, have you heard of it? Gan Xiaoyu?
Shure: 是张仁岳的那个吗
Shure: Is it the one by Zhang Renyue?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 这些歌我觉得很适合你吉它弹
Katrina: I think these songs are perfect for you to play on the guitar.
Shure: 降半音式C调效式D调阀音
Shure: Half-step down tuning in C, effective in D tuning valve sound.
Shure: 要唱他的原原调的是吗
Shure: Are we singing in the original key?
Katrina: 我不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina: 你会唱吗你要带一下
Katrina: Can you sing? You need to lead.
Shure: 好 我试一下
Shure: Okay, I'll give it a try.
Katrina: 你弹到哪了
Katrina: Where did you play up to?
Katrina: 弹完啦
Katrina: Finished playing?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 配合默契挺好啊
Shure: Our coordination is pretty good.
Katrina: 咱五两那个
Katrina: Like the five-two we had.
Katrina: 最后一句不会
Katrina: I can't do the last line.
Katrina: 好后面这首高潮
Katrina: Okay, next is the climax.
Katrina: 你带
Katrina: You lead.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 可以 来唱歌吧
Katrina: Okay, let's sing.
Katrina: 来唱歌
Katrina: Let's sing.
Shure: 毫无默契
Shure: No coordination at all.
Katrina: 完全拉跨
Katrina: Totally off.
Katrina: 你噫 什么你们这些有女朋友的
Katrina: Ugh, you guys with girlfriends.
Katrina: 好第一天坐你们车的时候知道学姐跟我说
Katrina: On the first day I rode with you, the senior told me.
Katrina: 她女朋友绝望吧
Katrina: His girlfriend must be desperate.
Katrina: 我说哦靠都有女朋友一车
Katrina: I was like, "Wow, everyone in the car has a girlfriend."
Katrina: 她是晒衣服吗
Katrina: Is she hanging clothes?
Katrina: 我们坐在伞下你坐进来
Katrina: We're sitting under the umbrella, come join us.
Shure: freestyle一段
Shure: Let's do a freestyle.
Katrina: 嗯从哪开始呢
Katrina: Hmm, where to start?
Katrina: 还是前观比较熟
Katrina: The front part is more familiar.
Shure: 我意思是你根据我的这个
Shure: I mean, you follow my lead.
Katrina: 啊我听不出啥调
Katrina: Ah, I can't tell the key.
Shure: 想到什么唱什么
Shure: Just sing whatever comes to mind.
Shure: 试一下嗯
Shure: Give it a try, mm.
Katrina: 唉不行
Katrina: Ah, can't do it.
Katrina: 这下这下难受了
Katrina: This is too hard now.
Katrina: 让他唱
Katrina: Let him sing.
Shure: 傻子
Shure: Silly.
Katrina: 你们俩一个宿舍的吗
Katrina: Are you two in the same dorm?
Katrina: 是他在我隔壁不打
Katrina: He's in the next room, doesn't bother me.
Katrina: 不是 他在我隔壁
Katrina: No, he's next to me.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 这是你自已随便调的啊
Katrina: Did you just adjust this randomly?
Katrina: 哎还挺好听耶
Katrina: Hey, it sounds pretty good.
Shure: 下雨了
Shure: It's raining.
Katrina: 这这都那个弹得老天都哭了
Katrina: This playing is so moving even the heavens are crying.
Katrina: 来吧今天就主攻唯一了
Katrina: Come on, let's focus on the main piece today.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 你也为弹吉它啊
Katrina: Are you going to play the guitar too?
Shure: 他可以速速成一下
Shure: He can master it quickly.
Katrina: 唯一有那个吗
Katrina: Does "the one and only" have that?
Nicous: 把我的琴带了
Nicous: I brought my instrument.
Shure: 什么琴
Shure: Which instrument?
Shure: 钢琴
Shure: Piano.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 这不是唯一
Shure: This isn't "the one and only".
Katrina: 唯一被你删了是不是
Katrina: Did you delete "the one and only"?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 你不用管他这个
Shure: Don't worry about this.
Shure: 这个你摁到摁到这个1 2
Shure: Just press here, on 1 and 2.
Katrina: 刚学啊这是
Katrina: Are you just learning this?
Shure: 3 对这样
Shure: Yes, like this.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 不对
Shure: No, that's wrong.
Shure: 没摁上食指食指往上窜一点对嗯
Shure: You didn't press it properly, move your index finger up a bit. Yes, like that.
Shure: 你可以不用摁着弹
Shure: You don't have to press while playing.
Shure: 你别看这不用弹前奏了
Shure: Don't worry about the intro.
Shure: 你就把和弦先摁明白得了
Shure: Just get the chords right first.
Shure: 还想弹前奏
Shure: You still want to play the intro?
Shure: 悟性很高
Shure: You have a high aptitude.
Katrina: 录一个你发你女朋友吧
Katrina: Record it and send it to your girlfriend.
Shure: 这个可以
Shure: That's a good idea.
Katrina: 刚录上
Katrina: Just started recording.
Shure: EM就可以只摁这两
Shure: For EM, just press these two.
Shure: 不不不用弹那个
Shure: No, no, don't play that part.
Shure: 只摁这俩
Shure: Just these two.
Shure: 对吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 去
Katrina: Go.
Shure: 看谁不轻易
Shure: Let's see who won't easily...
Shure: 嗯魔音罐耳
Shure: Hmm, magic sound jar.
Shure: 我已经成功教会谢彬竹吉它了
Shure: I've successfully taught Xie Binzhu the guitar.
Jake:弹一弹一首
Jake: Play a song.
Jake:这个应该怎么弹全吗
Jake: Should I play the whole thing?
Shure: 就这个样
Shure: Just like this.
Shure: 你可以同时
Shure: You can simultaneously...
Nicous: OK我已经悟了
Nicous: OK, I get it now.
Shure: 你悟个蛋
Shure: You get nothing.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 或者你这样爬音会更更好听一点
Shure: Or you can play it this way, it might sound better.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 他为啥金鸡独立呀
Katrina: Why is he standing on one leg?
Shure: 因为他坐着呢
Shure: Because he's sitting.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 他没有眼力见有些人
Shure: Some people just can't see.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 好你夺权吧
Shure: Alright, you take over.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 音绕梁
Katrina: The sound lingers.
Shure: 没事没事无所谓
Shure: It's alright, no worries.
Jake:他怎么样挺好
Jake: How's he doing?
Shure: 有天赋
Shure: Talented.
Shure: 说实话挺好
Shure: Honestly, pretty good.
Shure: 就是有的音没出音哦
Shure: Just some notes didn't come out right.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈你真的爱他吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, do you really love him? Hahaha.
Katrina: 犹豫了
Katrina: Hesitated.
Jake:我草
Jake: Damn.
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hello, yes?
Katrina: 哎呀搞蒙了
Katrina: Oh no, I'm confused.
Shure: 啊您京东快递到了是吗
Shure: Ah, is this the JD delivery?
Shure: 啊行我马上马上取一下
Shure: Ah, okay, I'll go pick it up right away.
Katrina: 你应该是学过一点吧
Katrina: You must have learned a bit, right?
Shure: 啊知道吧
Shure: Ah, you know?
Shure: 啊您您要不给我先放放这先
Shure: Ah, can you leave it here for now?
Katrina: 有的他要琢磨半天按哪几格
Katrina: Sometimes he takes a while to figure out which frets to press.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: 那反正我们这边好像让什么管家去取
Shure: Anyway, it seems like we have someone to pick it up.
Shure: 应该你就放放在那应该他就能找到
Shure: Just leave it there, they should be able to find it.
Shure: 啊好嘞成谢谢你
Shure: Alright, got it, thanks.
Katrina: 哎呀没点东西
Katrina: Oh no, nothing here.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: em正常要怎么按
Shure: Um, how do you normally press it?
Shure: 他那个是EM钢狙是以狙狙为根音的
Shure: That EM steel sniper is based on the root note of the sniper.
Shure: EM正常是这么按
Shure: This is how you normally press EM.
Shure: 正常不是
Shure: Normally it's not.
Shure: 正常就是他就是这么按的
Shure: Normally, you press it like this.
Shure: 这是正常的EM因为它的根音是咪这样
Shure: This is the normal EM because its root note is "mi."
Shure: 然后它那是EM杠狙嘛
Shure: And that one is the EM steel sniper.
Shure: 就是它的根根音是这样的
Shure: So its root note is like this.
Shure: 你也可以
Shure: You can also...
Shure: 我也没不知道有什么其他办法可以
Shure: I don't know if there's any other way to do it.
Shure: 应该可以这样
Shure: It should work like this.
Shure: 人类早期驯服吉他影像实录
Shure: Early humans taming the guitar, a documentary.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Shure: 你好哎呦
Shure: Hi there, ouch!
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 会唱私奔吗
Shure: Can you sing "Elopement"?
Katrina: 你京东这是买啥 呀
Katrina: What did you buy on JD?
Shure: 咖啡绿植
Shure: Coffee and plants.
Shure: 就这么无趣
Shure: Just that boring.
Shure: 这够简单了哥
Shure: This is simple enough, bro.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Nicous: 妈妈说
Nicous: Mom said...
Shure: 妈妈说是谁的
Shure: Mom said whose...
Shure: 不用想这更更难想象
Shure: Don't think, it's even harder to imagine.
Shure: 就告5人
Shure: Just tell five people.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 就这仨和弦从头到尾就哭哭弹
Shure: Just these three chords from start to finish, just play them.
Nicous: 这个就不弹直接过好吧
Nicous: Just skip this one, okay?
Shure: 你可以这样
Shure: You can do this.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 你也纱球纱球
Katrina: You also "sha qiu sha qiu."
Shure: 对然后在哪歘歘歘
Shure: Right, and then "xue xue xue."
Shure: 别搜了这样弹不来的
Shure: Stop searching, you can't play it that way.
Shure: 你别这么说
Shure: Don't say that.
Shure: 我给你搜来
Shure: I'll find it for you.
Shure: 百度AI助力中国航天是什么
Shure: Baidu AI supports China's aerospace, what is it?
Shure:  妈妈说
Shure: Mom said...
Katrina:  我也不知道回啥了
Katrina: I don't know what to reply.
Katrina:  还要回吗
Katrina: Are we going back?
Shure: 什吗
Shure: What?
Katrina:  就是她说的那个话以后
Katrina: Like what she said afterward.
Shure:  没事
Shure: It's fine.
Katrina:  大师你怎么说
Katrina: Master, what do you say?
Shure: 我看看他说什么来着
Shure: Let me see what he said.
Nicous:  好吧男的女的
Nicous: Okay, is it a guy or girl?
Nicous:  老了少了
Nicous: Old or young?
Katrina:  我回啥
Katrina: What should I say back?
Katrina:  他跟我说他不想谈爱
Katrina: He told me he doesn't want to talk about love.
Shure:  哦对对对
Shure: Oh right, right, right.
Shure:  废话你他妈的呵呵呵呵
Shure: No wonder he was like, "Ha ha ha ha."
Katrina:  瞎讲讲半天他妈服务器没开一个地方
Katrina: Talking all this nonsense and the server isn't even up.
Shure: 脑袋
Shure: Brain.
Shure:  哎呀哎呀嗯嗯
Shure: Oh my, oh my, mmhmm.
Nicous:  北欧那个
Nicous: That Nordic guy?
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Mmhmm.
Nicous:  跟你谈恋爱了
Nicous: He talked about dating you?
Shure:  哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: Oh my goodness.
Nicous:  打开我看地一下
Nicous: Let me open it and take a look.
Katrina:  没谈上人家又说不想谈恋
Katrina: He didn't want to date and said he didn't want to.
Nicous:  哦他说不想谈这这个不想谈就不谈
Nicous: Oh, he said he doesn't want to date, so don't.
Shure:  爱
Shure: Love.
Shure:  他现在只有单线程
Shure: He's single-threaded right now.
Shure:  我跟你讲他很暴躁
Shure: I'm telling you, he's quite irritable.
Katrina:  那就不回了
Katrina: Then don't reply.
Katrina:  不知道回啥
Katrina: No idea what to say.
Katrina:  这人真怪呀
Katrina: This guy is really weird.
Katrina:  你觉得呢还是说你也这样
Katrina: What do you think? Or are you like that too?
Shure:  我不这样啊我要真喜欢我就哭哭晚上冲
Shure: I'm not like that. If I really liked someone, I'd go all out.
Shure:  我觉你看我在一颗树上吊死四年了
Shure: Look, I've been hanging on to this one tree for four years.
Shure:  哦我还没说完呢
Shure: Oh, I haven't finished.
Shure:  之前那个跟另一个女关系特好的时候然后她那个
Shure: When I was close with another girl before, she was interning.
Shure:  有段时间在实习嘛
Shure: She was interning for a while.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Mmhmm.
Shure:  嗯然后实习结束了
Shure: Yeah, and when the internship ended,
Shure:  说找我那个出去喝个酒
Shure: she asked me out for a drink.
Shure:  放松一下
Shure: To relax a bit.
Jake: 要不就
Jake: So then...
Shure: 然后我就去了
Shure: And then I went.
Shure: 嗯然后那天
Shure: Hmm, and then that day
Shure: 然后就跟我正在关系好的那个女生说
Shure: I was talking to the girl I'm close with
Shure: 我今天天气很不错耶然后
Shure: I said, "The weather is really nice today," and then
Shure: 我直接把这句话给打断了
Shure: I just interrupted myself
Shure:  但是我今天要跟前女友出去喝酒
Shure: and said, "But I'm going out drinking with my ex today."
Katrina:  你也够抽象啊
Katrina: You really are something else
Katrina:  他不是正跟你聊得好吗
Katrina: Wasn't he having a good conversation with you?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yeah
Shure:  但是就是你知道
Shure: But you know
Shure:  在我这个脑子系统下
Shure: In my brain's system
Shure:  下一页要他们付费的
Shure: The next page requires payment
Shure: 付费个头可以
Shure: Forget about the payment
Nicous:  可麻烦了耶
Nicous: That's really troublesome
Shure:  就在我的脑子里面
Shure: Just in my mind
Shure: 他永远排在一个最优先
Shure: She is always a priority
Katrina:  啊就是前女友永远适合这样
Katrina: Ah, the ex-girlfriend is always like that
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then?
Shure:  不知道我不知道他他当时谈
Shure: I don't know, I don't know if she was dating someone at the time
Shure:  反正我我不在乎他谈没谈
Shure: Anyway, I didn't care if she was dating or not
Shure:  就是当时
Shure: At that time
Shure:  一直就是把他当出来喝酒一起玩的朋友那种
Shure: I just treated her as a friend to go out drinking and have fun with
Katrina: 啊这样子
Katrina: Ah, I see
Shure:  就是咋唱都不记你还在这弹呢
Shure: No matter how you sing, you still play here
Shure:  你先你先学咋唱
Shure: You should first learn how to sing
Nicous: 你先帮我把第二页绑起来
Nicous: First help me bind the second page
Shure:  你先把第一页学会我给你搞
Shure: You learn the first page first, I'll help you
Katrina:  哎我好像听过这个歌
Katrina: Hey, I think I've heard this song
Katrina:  像你家晕的比较轻偏RNB
Katrina: It sounds like your family prefers light R&B
Shure:  的时代已经过去了
Shure: 调一下
Shure: Adjust it
Shure:  你再从从头放一下
Shure: Play it from the beginning again
Shure:  你不要从这么头
Shure: Not from the very beginning
Shure: 打个灯
Shure: Turn on the light
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn
Shure:  大点声音乐
Shure: Turn up the music volume
Jake: 雨轩老师
Jake: Mr. Yuxuan
Jake: 你的快递那个笔有到吗
Jake: Did your express delivery with the pen arrive?
Katrina:  不知道他取没有
Katrina: I don't know if he picked it up
Jake: 看对看一下
Jake: Let's check then
Jake: 如果有的话能有点用
Jake: If there is, it might be useful.
Katrina:  他说已签收啊
Katrina: He said it's been signed for.
Katrina:  那他去拿了吧
Katrina: So he probably picked it up.
Katrina:  已签收没签收的话他会发
Katrina: If it's signed for, he'll post it.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯看一看
Jake: Hmm, let's take a look.
Shure:  这个四五
Shure: This is a 45.
Shure:  我们可以一起创作一些非常简单的东西
Shure: We can create some really simple stuff together.
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Shure:  就比如说随便弹一个掉的 1645
Shure: Like just play a random 1645 chord progression.
Shure:  就这种
Shure: Like this.
Shure:  好雨宣老师填词
Shure: Okay, Rain will write the lyrics.
Shure:  啥玩意现在就拿着你的论文开始唱出来
Shure: What? Now you start singing your thesis.
Katrina:  草履虫变异
Katrina: Paramecium mutation.
Shure:  我觉得草
Shure: I think...
Katrina:  别说我以前还干过挺蠢的事追星的时候干过
Katrina: Don't laugh, I did some pretty silly things back in my fangirling days.
Katrina:  帮人家站填词
Katrina: Like writing lyrics for fansites.
Katrina:  然后我就决定换一个小夜灯
Katrina: Then I decided to switch to a night light.
Katrina: 但是那是有原来的词
Katrina: But there were original lyrics.
Katrina:  然后你在去押韵
Katrina: Then you had to make it rhyme.
Shure:  我们就叫草履虫变异来吧
Shure: Let's call it Paramecium Mutation.
Katrina: 草履虫变异了
Katrina: Paramecium mutated.
Shure:  然后还有什么
Shure: And what else?
Shure:  哈哈哒哒哒
Shure: Hahaha da da da.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  叫什么命题作文
Shure: What's it called, a themed essay?
Katrina:  草履虫草履虫
Katrina: Paramecium, paramecium.
Katrina:  变异
Katrina: Mutation.
Shure:  好你又学会了
Shure: Okay, you got it.
Nicous:  他估计就是爱
Nicous: He probably just loves...
Shure:  对韩黛姬对
Shure: Yeah, Han Daeki, right.
Shure:  爱很简单
Shure: Love is simple.
Katrina:  我靠唱这首歌
Katrina: Wow, singing this song...
Katrina:  给你看这个
Katrina: Look at this.
Shure:  这是谁写的
Shure: Who wrote this?
Katrina: 北邮男
Katrina: A guy from Beiyou.
Shure:  哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, oh.
Katrina:  当时我俩不是一起去看那个音乐节吗
Katrina: Weren't we at that music festival together?
Katrina:  然后去听陶喆
Katrina: Listening to David Tao.
Katrina:  然后这是那一首嗯
Katrina: And this was the song, yeah.
Katrina:  叫什么
Katrina: What's it called?
Katrina:  是爱很简单吗
Katrina: Is love very simple?
Katrina:  不是爱很简单
Katrina: No, love isn't simple.
Katrina:  就是爱你就是爱你那首的词
Katrina: It's the lyrics from "Just Love You".
Katrina:  我说我特喜欢这词
Katrina: I said I really like these lyrics.
Katrina:  我说就是对我来说就很有意义吧
Katrina: I said it means a lot to me.
Katrina:  然后他第二天早上把我送到高铁站的时候
Katrina: Then the next morning, when he took me to the high-speed rail station,
Katrina:  一句话没说
Katrina: he didn't say a word.
Katrina:  然后给我塞一张纸条说高铁上看
Katrina: Then he slipped me a note saying, "Read it on the train."
Shure:  哎呀他好坏呀他
Shure: Oh, he's so bad, isn't he?
Shure:  他这个歌
Shure: This song of his...
Shure:  我靠都给你吊成翘嘴了我跟你讲
Shure: Wow, he really hooked you, I'm telling you.
Katrina:  所以所以这么久了还没有完全忘掉吗
Katrina: So, so even after so long, I still haven't completely forgotten?
Katrina:  然后那天去看脱口秀特搞笑你知道吗
Katrina: Then that day, we went to watch a stand-up comedy show. It was so funny, you know?
Katrina:  我给他看他看我手机那里面的东西
Katrina: I showed him, and he looked at the stuff on my phone.
Katrina:  看他他说哎你说换手机他就换
Katrina: He said, "Hey, you said you'd change your phone, so change it."
Katrina:  马上哈哈哈哈当时看看我咬的哈哈
Katrina: Immediately, haha, at that moment, look at what I bit, haha.
Shure:  哈他在钓你你快咬钩吧
Shure: Haha, he's fishing for you. You should bite the hook quickly.
Shure:  你应该跟他说等等我
Shure: You should tell him, "Wait for me."
Shure:  我这就上钩
Shure: "I'm biting the hook right now."
Katrina:  被吊这么久了呀
Katrina: He's been fishing for so long.
Katrina:  11月份到现在
Katrina: Since November until now.
Katrina:  觉得不能
Katrina: I feel like I can't.
Shure: 一会谢冰珠手打结了
Shure: In a while, Xie Bingzhu's hands will be tied in knots.
Katrina:  陶喆歌可难了
Katrina: David Tao's song is really difficult.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure:  哎呦我操你好像高潮了一样哈哈哈
Shure: Wow, you look like you just had an orgasm, haha.
Shure:  哎呀我操
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina:  每次那个演唱会和那个音乐节最后
Katrina: Every time at the end of a concert or music festival,
Katrina:  都是这首歌
Katrina: it's always this song.
Katrina:  每次听都哭
Katrina: Every time I hear it, I cry.